[Music]
hey you guys
time once again for tomes of terror my
book review show
got kind of an interesting one today
this is a
japanese thriller mystery
psychological horror type of book and it
is called
confessions by kanai manato
hopefully i'm pronouncing that right or
at least in the ballpark
if if i didn't i'm very sorry so this is
miss minato's first novel uh apparently
she used to work in the educational
system she was a teacher or something of
that nature and she was also a housewife
evidently she wrote this book like
in between chores like on the weekends
and in the evenings
this book apparently it first came out
in 2008
in japan and it was a massive
hit there um so i guess that they that
the publisher was kind of like what was
such a big hit in japan that they wanted
to say they did a bunch of translations
and it henceforth became a very very
large like international kind of book
sensation i had hadn't heard about it
when it came out but i heard about it
probably six months ago or something
like that when i heard somebody on
goodreads or something like
talking about it yeah please correct me
if i'm wrong but i believe there was a
short film i don't think it was a
feature length film but i think there
was a short film
that was based on this novel but i have
not seen it so i'm basically just going
uh
by the book now i will say i'm not going
to spoil
anything directly like any big plot
twists or anything like that
but this is going to be kind of mildly
spoilery because it's really really hard
to talk about without talking about some
of the plot points
and kind of conveying like how deeply
twisted and messed up this [ __ ] book
is
because it is now it's not gory or
nothing like that it's not gory at all
it's just very psychologically [ __ ] up
okay so
this if you like that kind of thing then
you will probably really dig this
so the writing style of this is actually
very direct very straightforward
just like the last book i talked about
which was the nightmare room by chris
sorensen
i basically read almost this entire book
like in one sitting
um i think what ended up happening with
this one is like i read the first
section and kind of looked over time and
said this book is [ __ ] up
like already like at the end of the
first section and then like the
following evening i was like oh i'm you
know i'd really like to finish this book
and i think i pretty much like finished
it
other than the last cut like couple of
pages and um so it's so so it's a really
quick read it's not like
you know it's not real dense literary
fiction or anything like that it's very
very easy to read
it's also in kind of an epistolary style
um if you don't know what that is it's
usually people that are like you know
it's told through
letters you know journal entries blog
entries
you know people talking so it's set up
in six
chapters but they're really long
chapters um so they're more it's more
like sections with like six sections
and each section is from a different
character's point of view either
something they're
saying like a lecture they're giving or
something that they wrote to somebody
like a letter that they wrote to
somebody
and it's interesting because it almost
you almost get this kind of thing where
it's kind of the same situation
that they're talking about but you're
seeing other people's perspective on it
and so
as the book goes on and each character
gives their
version of the story or you know their
part that they played in the story that
you didn't like know about
it kind of you know opens up like new
like peeling off layers of an onion
you know what i mean so it's not it's
not just a kind of case where
six people are like talking about the
exact same thing it's like they're
talking about same aspects
you know of this big overarching kind of
plot
now the plot for this it's basically a
revenge story
the first section of the book is told
from the point of view of a middle
school
teacher and her name is yuko moriguchi
now it's interesting because she's
addressing uh members of her class
and at first you're not really sure
what her lecture is getting at like she
kind of has them stay after school
because there's something important that
she wants to tell them
so at first she's kind of going all over
the map she's talking about
uh this program that the school had
started that was trying to get like all
the japanese school children like to
drink milk because it was good for them
and so they came in with like free milk
every day and everybody drank it and had
their own little
you know carton with their name on it
and the little cubby and everything
so she's talking about that then she's
talking about
another teacher who was a mentor of hers
and so she's talking about a couple of
things that seem like they're unrelated
and then as she as her talk goes on
she gets to kind of the meat of the
issue
the meat of the issue is that her little
girl
minami who was four years old um she
would bring her to the school sometimes
like if she had to work late because she
was a single mother and she didn't have
anybody to watch her
so the little girl would come to the
school and like sometimes the other
girls would play with her
she would like put her in the office and
people would watch her and things like
that
but it came to pass that one day
manami had wandered off to feed a
neighbor's dog
and ended up but what appeared to be
falling into the pool
and drowning at the school now at first
you're thinking because she's telling
the
students that she's retiring so
everybody thinks oh well because of the
tragedy because you know obviously her
four-year-old daughter died and it was
very terrible and it was an accident
but then as she goes on she basically
says like drops the bombshell
that no actually manami was not it
wasn't an accident she was murdered by
two of you
and i know who it is with that kind of
revelation she kind of goes on and on
about
she's like well i found out who it was
like a while and they confessed and all
this other stuff
because she kind of goes on and on too
about child killers and about how much
leeway um is given to
children who kill um so she's kind of
talking about that
she's kind of talking about it like from
a japanese cultural standpoint like
it's becoming more common like for you
know really little kids to become
murderers
because they want attention or they want
to get famous or something like that so
she goes a little bit into that as well
so she's basically saying well i don't
really trust the justice system
to deal with you children because these
kids are like 13 14 years old
um so i'm going to exact my own revenge
on you while letting the police continue
to think that monami's death was
accidental so basically what she does
and like i said mild spoilers mild
spoilers because i didn't know this
going in
and like this was the thing this was the
revelation
in the first section of the book that
maybe go man the shit's [ __ ] up
so if you don't want to know then turn
it off now because it's going to get
like kind of spoilery from here on out
so basically what she did the reason she
was bringing up all the stuff
earlier about uh you know the free milk
program and all that other kind of stuff
and this other
teacher that was her mentor that she
admired the reason she was bringing that
up is because one
the teacher she admired was also her
fiance at some point
but they had decided not to get married
manami was his daughter as well
they had decided not to get married
because it turned out that he had
aids and he was dying and he didn't want
to like burden her
so they kind of they were still like
friends and stuff but they didn't really
like
i guess he didn't want to burden her or
whatever that was kind of important to
know and she said that the revenge that
she was taking on these two boys
that murdered her daughter was that she
had taken
some of this dude's blood like without
his knowledge
and had injected it into the milk
cartons that were going to those two
little boys
thereby she i think that you don't
really find out until later on that she
was just like well
i didn't really care one way the other
if you got aids or not
i just wanted you to worry about it so
that
you know you would know what it was like
like to know that your death was coming
or something like that so that was kind
of her revenge and this is like i said
this is only the first section
of the book from her point of view and
then from there like the second
section um is told from the point of
view of another
girl in the class um and she is writing
a letter
back to uh yugo moriguchi
like telling her what happened
subsequently like after she retired
and they got a new teacher to come in so
she's kind of talking about
another thing that moriguchi wanted to
do was that
she wanted it to get around that the two
boys had aids like she wanted to tell
everybody so that everybody would treat
them like pariahs and would start
bullying them
so that was like another tendril of her
revenge also
so this girl is kind of telling what
happened now she ended up getting
bullied too because
it was kind of like this lord of the
flies situation where everyone just kind
of turned on it and that if you
if they perceived that you thought that
you were sympathetic toward one of the
child killers then they would turn on
you as well and they so
all that [ __ ] up [ __ ] happened and
then you know as it goes on like more
and more aspects of this
revenge plot um kind of come to the fore
now there are actually two sections of
the book um
are told from the point of view of the
two boys
so you can get some insight into why
they did what they did
and the one kid the two kids names were
were shuya
and naoki and one of them was kind of
like the mastermind
it's it was a weird kind of situation
because one of them was a mastermind
he was like a genius and he was one of
those really like
you know and you have to think this
kid's like only 13 or 14 years old he's
one of those like weirdly like
nietzschean kids where
he thinks because he's smarter than
everyone else or he's better at school
than everybody else then he can just
like do what he wants to
so he's basically he had a mom who was
an electrical engineer and she like
taught him all of this
stuff so he knows how to like build all
these things you know he really likes to
invent stuff
and it turned out that one of the things
he invented weirdly was like this
change purse that would electrocute you
if you touched it at first it wouldn't
electrocute you and like kill you
because he wanted to take it to the
science fair as like oh it's an
anti-theft device like if somebody tries
to steal it
steal it they'll you know it'll electro
keep them or shock them
but he had built like an amped up
version and that was what he he wanted
to
experiment on someone to see if it
worked or not see if it would kill a
person
and so that's when they settled on
manami
you know the little four-year-old girl
that came around the school and
everybody knew whose daughter that was
and what not
but it turned out that the shock
actually they thought it killed her but
it didn't
and then so what ended up happening was
that
the that guy left and then the other kid
that was there
saw that the girl girl was still alive
and thought oh [ __ ] we're gonna get in
trouble and then threw in the pool and
drown her
so they were both like kind of
responsible for the murder like
you know in that way you know they each
kind of tell their side of the story
and then um you know one of the
murderers
sisters and moms like has a say
and uh you know so it's just like this
really long
i mean it's not long but it's just like
this really complicated
revenge tale and the end of it
is great too because i mean as like all
this [ __ ]
unfolds about you know the aids and the
bullying and
what really happened like why the kids
did what they did like what their
motivations were
and um all this other stuff it kind of
comes to the fore
that um and as i said again this is i'm
not saying exactly what happened but
it's like kind of mild spoilery
it kind of turns out that yuka moriguchi
the teacher from the beginning who did
the aids milk and everything
she had like this big master plan like
even
more than that as the book goes on
there's like just more and more
details being added to her
like nefarious revenge so it's really
this book like i said it is so so
twisted
not in the sense of it being like gross
or anything like that
it's just the frightening thing about
this book is that everybody
in it there's really not that many
likeable characters but that's okay
that's not like a ding against it
because the characters are
fascinating even though they're most of
them are really really unlikable
even the ones that are kind of unlikable
and the [ __ ] that they do is
like not forgivable you can understand
why they did it that's what's so great
about this book is that no matter
how shitty like the stuff that the
people in this book do
you can un you can't condone it but you
understand
how somebody might have come to that
past where they would actually do that
kind of [ __ ]
so nothing seems crazy nothing seems
like it none of them seem
psychotic or that they have anything
wrong with them necessarily like in a
big splashy kind of way
all of them seem like real relatable
people who are just put into these
particular situations and
acted accordingly so you can kind of so
like i said you're not condoning like
what they do because everybody in this
book is pretty
shitty even though some of their actions
are understandable
but it's still like a really fascinating
and really like
dark look you know not just um
at kids that commit crimes but links
that people will go to to like get
revenge
if they think that the justice system
isn't going to give them any
satisfaction in that regard
so even though everyone's kind of a
villain everything is just completely
you know the way it the way it plays out
is
pretty believable even though it is
super super messed up
and even though it's kind of super it's
kind of like a really
grim look at human nature i guess
but for all that i found it weirdly
entertaining even though it's
a really not fun exploration of like the
psychology of
not just terrible people but people in
general like pushed into certain
situations and how they might react
in maybe a way that from the outside
seems like really horrible
but it was just a fascinating
fascinating book and like i said that
some of the bombshells in this
i think when i was reading this book i
actually like gasped out loud
like a few times like when i was reading
it which i which i don't usually do a
lot
but it's like you know like at the end
of the first section at the end of i
think the second or third
section or something like that there was
just like this sentence at the end i was
like what you know what i mean so it was
just
it was just kind of doing that kind of
[ __ ] so
as i said i think this is probably
because i don't read a lot of manga or
anything like that
so i don't read a lot of japanese
fiction but this had gotten so many good
reviews i had seen it you know on some
other youtube channels that i watched
that have book reviews on them
i kept seeing this one coming up like in
the recommendations
and i was like man that sounds pretty
good it's like maybe i should check that
one out so definitely i think um
kanai manato has written a couple other
books since then because like i said
this came back
back in in 2008 so she's written a
couple cents and i'll definitely be
reading some more of her stuff because
this book was
phenomenal i really really enjoyed it
and it was like super messed up and
twisted which i love
um i will say that like i love that on
the cover of this
um this other writer called it if albert
camus had written heathers
which i guess that's kind of it and it
has like a
i guess it has a little bit asp of
aspect to of like battle royale
too but not that you know not that epic
or like violent or anything
this is more like an insidious nasty
like psychological revenge
horror you know what i mean and you will
just be like horrified like what the
people in this [ __ ] book do
but but not in a way that it's like oh
that's not believable or anything like
you can kind of see
how they got from a to b and i think
that's what's really like disturbing
about this book because i did find this
book like actually really really
disturbing
so you know if all that gushing didn't
clue you in um i would actually really
recommend this book if you're into
psychological horror
if you like asian horror if you like
anything that's like a revenge
type thriller anything like that or kind
of like a mystery
um i think you will really really dig
this you know like i said it
seems like it got like a big uh it made
a big splash when it came out like
in translation like around the world in
2008 or 2009 whatever it was
um but somehow it slipped under my radar
so i'm really glad i finally got around
to reading it
so as i said it's called confessions by
kanai manato
so definitely check it out and i will
see you on the next one
bye